we just witnessed what many people are
calling the greatest valorant match ever
played it ended with boaster Minnie and
durka finally lifting a trophy this
tournament was absolutely insane so
let's talk about it
last weekend we saw what could go down
as the greatest valorant match ever oh
my God oh my God
[Applause]
but before we get to that let's talk
about how we got to the final I've been
very critical of the format but Riot
definitely managed to put on quite the
spectacle we saw all 30 partner teams
and two Chinese rosters battle it out in
Do or Die matches and It produced some
of the most exciting Series valrant has
ever seen we got the NRG loud match up
that we've just come to expect another
top four finish for DRX and some
incredibly hype moments throughout the
event
far away from being back online to see
because my give it to him it is going to
be the res instead but he's gonna go
swinging
it's up to get to 1v3 first shot found
one two three
that is absurd he drops down no way
certainly not
just the best you cannot do this
unbelievable
the Hometown Favorites fought their way
to the Grand finals after some extremely
tense matches well fnatic entered the
finals without dropping a single map it
was set to be a battle of Titans but
before we get into that I want to talk
about boaster mini and durka these three
have been with fnatic from the very
beginning competing at ballarat's first
ever International land in Reykjavik
Iceland where they fell short to
Sentinels in the grand finals
unfortunately ever since that event
fnatic just haven't lived up to
expectations they made a number of
roster changes over the past couple
years but they've never managed to make
it back to a grand final that was until
this past weekend where boaster and
fnatic had a chance to do what Sentinels
did in Iceland they had the opportunity
to become only the second team to ever
win an entire tournament without
dropping a single map and as soon as the
match got underway it looked like they
were going to do exactly that top of the
spike seeing if they can force
positionings Chronicle unaware of any
the players in his sight lines a bit
drop down down two to two V two and both
is taking it half into the fuse gets out
of his life and Leo what is that just
nigh impossible
to keep them in the map
on their favorite stationary ground
still held down and that 13th round is
claimed fanatic off to a fantastic lead
how does this get taken
just on across Chronicle
two phone Aftershock pushes them away
but it's all too little and all too late
fnatic were one map away from making
history and lifting the trophy but loud
weren't willing to get embarrassed and
roll over in front of their home fans
they began mounting their comeback on
split and Lotus where Lassen sadok
pulled off some truly heroic rounds
looks like they wait pause for a moment
and Dirk is going to Walt in 20 seconds
left it's everything showstopper
exchange but look at that
stayed by Nano swarm reset left with
four so uncertain but a skipping away
angle watch for Pure reflexes pure
precision
two players full containment Fleck to
the side as fast might be good for two
jiggling the movement everything to play
for and every player falling I'll do it
and this is where every fnatic fan
started sweating everyone including
myself thought that they had bottled it
after map 4 it genuinely seemed like
loud were destined to pull off the first
reverse sweep in the men's circuit and
it didn't help at the start of map 5 was
an absolute disaster for fnatic a safe
plant and an ALT online covers in has
The Seekers and it's time to let them
loose
corralling finding their targets pushing
forwards kawazine nothing left unset
nothing left Untold
and it's just a collapse
inexual is the feeling loud with a 9-3
lead after heading into the second half
at a 9-3 deficit fnatic lost the second
pistol round and found themselves down
11-3 at this point the game felt over
fnatic had let the series slip away and
I didn't see any way for them to get
back into this game but then they proved
me and everyone else wrong jet Falls
it's all down to Alpha yet
noise everywhere in a double swing
right down
they must play through and it's a
collateral fanatic have essentially
got this one all tied up
one round away
and the fight is over
14-12 denying the reverse sweep fnatic
they pull off the impossible
I've watched Valor and Esports since the
game first came out and during that time
we've been treated to some incredible
matches what fnatic did on map 5 will go
down as one of the greatest comebacks in
the game's history this match had me on
the edge of my seat and I genuinely felt
like I was watching a anime by
the end of it Riot scriptwriters truly
outdid themselves with this event it
takes a truly special leader to bring a
game back like that and fnatic
absolutely deserved it Leo looked like a
freak throughout the series and they
couldn't have accomplished this win
without Alpha year and Chronicle this
win provided some nice revenge for Alpha
year who watched loud lift the champion
trophy in his native country of Turkey
last year and Chronicle is now the only
Pro to win two international events but
fnatics trophy lift sparked an entirely
different discussion throughout the
event fans pointed out the poor
attendance for non-brazilian teams but
to be fair Riot only opened up more
seats for those matches for the second
half of the tournament the attendance
definitely improved but most of the
community was critical of the fact that
a lot of fans left the venue before
fnatic even lifted the trophy Tarik even
commented on this on his stream my
message to Brazilians is to please
advocate for fellow Brazilians to start
showing love for these other teams
because otherwise just like I said uh
you know Ryan's not going to want to
come back and I think being here is
important like this is a big part it's a
big part of the game Brazil is such an
important uh aspect of it all so I think
we want to be here we just we can't push
us away like that now I understand where
both sides are coming from I wish that
Spectators would stick around and show
their love for the esport as a whole but
I also understand that after watching
your team lose in heartbreaking fashion
you probably just want to get the hell
out of there Tara clarified his message
on Sunday by tweeting in An Empty Arena
for a trophy lift is simply
heartbreaking to see but I do think it's
worth mentioning that throughout the
event fans have been complaining about
the insane temperatures within the venue
this is something that I reported on
back when the event got underway and it
seems like it was an issue throughout on
day one of the event hansi tweeted that
it was hotter than Satan's and
on day two she tweeted that it was so
hot that she felt lightheaded and to be
fair to the Brazilian fans I think this
is worth mentioning because although
they didn't back every team the crowd
was hype as for a lot of matches
boaster even tweeted yesterday that
there's no need for an apology from the
Brazilian fans unfortunately fnatics
players also tweeted that their trophy
didn't make it home in one piece overall
I think lock-in was an incredible way to
kick off the 2023 season we witnessed
the greatest best of five ever played
and with every event that goes by I'm
amazed that I'm still able to fall more
in love with this esport I'm excited to
see what the rest of the season holds
even if my team C9 are currently
imploding
like I'm not kidding like when I say I
was like on the edge of my seat like I I
physically was sitting on the edge like
what the is going on
like the back and forth was just so
insane like I thought I thought fnatic
had just completely bottled it and then
they go down 11-3 on map five I'm like
oh my God like I felt so bad for fnatic
and like their fans I was like oh geez